what does the day today look like for a
witch what's the fact from fiction I can
tell you from my experience what we were
doing we w't running running around in
in BR sticks or doing those type of
things but for us it was it was normal
waking up every every day set up some
candles and cleansings for the house
doing some also cleansings on our on on
ourselves preparing for for the day um
and just taking with us all the sections
the crystals these type of things
reading tarot cards that's kind of like
our day-to-day look like um and then
when we were outside as I said we never
said to anyone like we are witches we
are doing this we would just walk around
and be normal people